ici des centaines de paille de feutre
ici des modistes la découpeuse tous
travaillent dans le secret de leurs
ateliers et une fois une seule fois par
an c'est la fête la sainte catherine
cest un mois de travail acharné plus de
50 chapeau au final mais au fond on
quelle satisfaction c'est la récréation
pour nous c'est une façon de participer
un petit peu à la fête de chaque maison
pour lesquels on travaille toute l'année
et pour ses mousquetaires de la haute
couture
on ne recule devant aucun sacrifice
l'essayage en fait d'ailleurs partie il
faut le cahier des charges du jaune
symbole du mariage manqué du vert
symbole de l'espérance uniquement pour
ses chapeaux ludique c'est dans la plus
pure tradition du luxe
autant dire un cadeau là ils sont
vraiment à l'unité ring pour elle donc
c'est vraiment une pièce de collection
mais ça je pense qu'ils en sont
conscientes et qu'elles vont le garder
précieusement
mais attention pourquoi c'est sainte
catherine
il faut être vierge avoir 25 ans et
toujours pas de mari un peu comme les à
emilie les fans de la fête chez chanel
la sainte catherine
c'est l'occasion d'un jour fériés pour
toutes les maisons de couture l'occasion
des cadeaux est l'occasion d'un grand
dîner de gala le tout offert par la
maison
de quoi entretenir l'esprit des kits
pensant surtout intégré en fait vraiment
aller à la maison ça fait plaisir
la femme catherine pour nous
c'est l'occasion de se rencontrer et de
parler de dîner ensemble
en ces temps de parité que les hommes se
rassurent pour eux sainte-catherine
c'est à la saint-nicolas mêmes critères
vierge pas mariés seule différence il
faut avoir 30 ans